Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
les mirages gravitationnels.
L'univers est une immense surface à
quatre dimensions : l'espace-temps,
sur laquelle se déplacent les astres.
Lorsqu'un corps massif est dans
l'espace-temps, il le déforme et le courbe.
Plus l'objet est massif, plus la
déformation va être prononcée.
Cette courbure de l'espace-temps est à
l'origine de l'attraction gravitationnelle,
qui permet à la Terre de tourner autour du Soleil,
comme une bille au fond d'un bol.
Il se trouve que la lumière elle-même
est affecté par cette déformation.
En se déplaçant dans l'univers, un
faisceau lumineux va emprunter le chemin
le plus court possible. Dans un univers
classique, non courbé,
le chemin le plus court est une ligne droite.
Mais dans un univers courbé, le chemin le plus court est également courbé,
car il suit la
déformation de l'espace-temps.
Ainsi un faisceau lumineux, en provenance
d'une étoile ou d'une galaxie, va
être très légèrement dévié en
passant à côté d'un astre.
Mais cette déviation reste infime, et
négligeable.
Mais si le corps est très massif, de
sorte à déformer l'espace-temps de
façon importante, alors le faisceau sera
fortement dévié.
De cette façon, un observateur sur Terre
serait en mesure de recevoir la lumière déviée.
En observant cette
lumière, on observe l'astre là où il
devrait se trouver, si l'espace n'était
pas courbe, et que le faisceau s'était
déplacé en ligne droite.
Ainsi on observe une image déformée,
et décalée par rapport à la vraie position de l'astre.
C'est ce phénomène qu'on appelle
lentille, ou mirage gravitationnel.
Les mirages gravitationnels sont
causés par des masses très importantes,
comme des amas de galaxies, ou des trous noirs.
Mais il est également possible d'observer des mirages
qui semblent n'être dus à aucun astre.
En réalité, ceux-ci sont causées par
une masse très importante, invisible,
qui compose un tiers de l'univers,
la matière noire.